am nordpol gibt es dramatische
veränderung der magnetische nordpol
dreht im wahrsten sinne des wortes durch
er wandert immer schneller durch die
gegend und bringt damit alles
durcheinander
jetzt ist er auf der reise von kanada
nach sibirien und die wissenschaft muss
reagieren was ist da los droht schon
eine umpolung des erdmagnetfeldes und
ist sie gefährlich klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes heinz videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen es ist soweit schon
wieder müssen sich experten und
expertinnen treffen um das modell zur
beschreibung des erdmagnetfeldes zu
korrigieren ansonsten läuft ja auf der
erde nämlich einiges schief navigation
oder auch google maps würden einen
falsch leiten denn auch das magnetfeld
dient zur navigation wenn das anders ist
als in der software hinterlegt dann geht
fährt und fliegt alles schief der grund
der nordpol wandert mit einer höheren
geschwindigkeit eigentlich sollte das
aktuelle modell bis zum jahr 2020 halten
aber es ist jetzt schon überholt ursache
der nordpol bewegt sich mit 55
kilometern pro jahr richtung sibirien
jetzt muss das modell dringend
überarbeitet werden damit sich
verkehrsmittel weiter zuverlässig auf
der erde fortbewegen können ansonsten
würde das chaos thron grund für das sich
verändernde magnetfeld sind ströme
flüssigen eisens in der erde sie
verändern im moment ihren fluss und
führen so zu den veränderungen und das
nicht nur am nordpol in kanada ist die
verschiebung des nordpols wohl eine
folge eines hochgeschwindigkeits eisen
jobs dort unter der oberfläche erscheint
aus zu schmieren so dass das magnetfeld
unter kanada abgeschwächt wird wodurch
sich das magnetfeld unter 7 im
verhältnis verstärkt aber weltweit
scheint es zu solchen phänomenen zu
kommen zwischen südafrika und südamerika
wird die kosmische strahlung immer
stärker und bedrohter tiere und personal
an bord von verkehrsflugzeugen eine
folge eines schwächer werdenden
magnetfeldes und auf hoher see vor
südafrika springen magnetische
kompassnadeln inzwischen hin
dort könnte jetzt ein dramatisches
ereignis seinen anfang nehmen die pole
umkehr zum letzten mal gab es sie vor
780.000 jahren und in einer
hochtechnisierten welt könnten die
folgen dramatisch sein
denn in der zeit der umpolung wird das
magnetfeld erst mal schwächer und lässt
gefährliche kosmische strahlung durch
neben der folgen für unsere gesundheit
könnten dann sonnenstürme unsere gesamte
zivilisation lahmlegen stromnetze
telekommunikation internet und so weiter
und so fort es würde zu einer
dramatischen herausforderungen für die
menschheit führen wie organisieren wir
dann mit total eingeschränkter
kommunikation und infrastruktur die
versorgung mit nahrung wärme und strom
es könnte zum millionen toten kommen
aber andersherum ist es auch keineswegs
sicher dass es zu einer pohl und er
kommt schon oft hat sich das
erdmagnetfeld abgeschwächt und ist dann
wieder erstarkt es wird und bleibt
spannend war spannend 2018 wie spannend
erfahrt ihr im ama wissenschaftstheorie
wein 2018 bei doktor watson mit ganz
vielen youtube wissenschafts kanälen
unbedingt hier anklicken richtig geiles
video
ich bin auch dabei und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran